you
the council will come to order
ladies and gentlemen please rise for the
posting of the colors by the Phoenix
Military Academy junior Reserve Officers
Training Corps
please remain standing for the Pledge of
Allegiance led by arturo by Asteras i
[Music]
pledge of allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
please remain standing for the national
anthem which will be sung by Miguel
Cervantes accompanied by the Chicago
Symphony era
[Music]
by
what's so proudly
at the twilight's last gleaming whose
broad stripes and bright stars through
the perilous the ramparts we watch'd
were so gallantly streaming and the
Rockets red glare the bombs bursting
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
No
over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
the invocation will be delivered by
Reverend dr. Bernard Jakes
I respectfully
ask that each of us would pause for a
moment as we seek guidance and blessings
for this respective occasion creator of
all that have gathered in this place is
with great joy that we gather to
celebrate the new possibilities that
await our city as we have gathered as a
beloved community we ask that your
presence be manifested in this
celebration the people of the city have
elected Lori Lightfoot and a Valencia
Melissa Kangas Irvin and this beautiful
bouquet of all the women and men to lead
us we pray you affirm their election
with your blessing on this day we are
grateful for your allowing us to
participate in the democracy of electing
officials but we also acknowledge this
allowance as your actions of favor grace
and love to and for your human creation
most beloved creator of all as your
presence has turned this eerie arena
into a place of radical encounter
because you are a God of justice and
love we petition you to grant that same
spirit of justice and love to our new
mayor as she prepares to lead our city
grant Lori the ability to imitate you
grant her wisdom to make the right
decisions give her power to lead justly
inspire her to walk humbly protect her
when others attack her and love her even
more strongly when others may show
insensitivity toward her we pray your
grace keeps her your mercy covers her
and your love protects her Amy and
Vivian as they began this new journey as
our first family a blessed creator as we
are gathered in this place
teach us to walk gently with our elected
servants as a beloved community guide us
as we seek justice together make peace
together walk in Hope together and may
the words of dr. Howard Thurman come
alive and both elected officials and
people don't ask what the world
means ask what makes you come alive and
go do it because what the world needs
are people who have come alive and as an
alive people we welcome and receive your
presence of love as we begin this
journey anew
with grateful and excited hearts we pray
amen
please welcome Alfreda burke and Rodrick
Dixon accompanied by Fred Nelson the
third
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll tell the story
[Music]
wait
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the prayer for
guidance will be delivered by imam Tariq
al-amin
[Applause]
may the peace that only God can give be
upon each and every one of you we pray
in the name of the all-seeing the
all-hearing the ever merciful creator of
the heavens and the earth with god's
name the merciful benefactor the
merciful Redeemer all praise is due to
God lord cherisher and sustainer of all
the systems of knowledge the merciful
benefactor the merciful Redeemer the
sole judge on the day of judgement you
alone do we worship and your aid alone
do we seek show us the straight way the
way of those on whom you have bestowed
your grace not the way of those who have
incurred your wrath know those who go
astray we pray for the guidance and
protection of those elected to serve the
city of Chicago we pray that as they
take the oath to uphold the Constitution
of the United States and the
constitution of the state of Illinois
that you keep these women and men
mindful of their own internal
Constitution
we pray that you keep them upright and
unbent we pray that you strengthen them
as only you can let them stand firmly
for peace let them stand firmly for
justice let them stand firmly for equity
no matter who stands on the other side
protect their eyes from blindness let
them see the people protect their ears
from deafness let them hear the people
protect their tongues from meaningless
speech let them speak directly to the
people protect their hearts from the
bitter winds of cynicism keep their
hearts softened towards the people dear
god guide them and give them success in
their endeavor to lead through service
because their success is our success
amen
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Chicago City Clerk
Ana Valencia
[Applause]
hi Andrea Murray Valencia I Andrea
Murray Valencia do solemnly swear do
solemnly swear that I will support the
Constitution of the United States that I
will support the Constitution of the
United States in the constitution of the
state of Illinois and the Constitution
of the state of Illinois and that I will
faithfully discharge the duties that I
will faithfully discharge the duties of
the office of clerk of the city of
Chicago of the office of clerk of the
city of Chicago according to the best of
my ability according to the best of my
ability congratulations thank you
[Applause]
my cheering section thank you will the
alderman elect of the 50 Ward's please
rise and please race raise your right
hand and repeat after me
I state your name do solemnly swear that
I will support the Constitution of the
United States and the Constitution of
the state of Illinois and that I will
faithfully discharge the duties of the
office of Alderman of the city of
Chicago according to the best of my
ability congratulations alderman and
alder women
[Applause]
alderman please be seated
the clerk will call the roll
alderman David la spada elderman Brian
Hopkins alderman pat-down
alderman Sophia keen all the men Leslie
Hairston aldermen Roderick Sawyer
Alderman Gregory Mitchell Aldrin
Michelle Harris Alderman Anthony vo
aldeman Susan Pulaski Garza
alderman Patrick Daly alderman Jorge
Cardenas
Alvin Marty Quinn alderman Edward Burke
alderman Raymond Lopez alderman
Stephanie Coleman alderman David Moore
alderman Derek Curtis alderman Matthew
O'Shea alderman janet Taylor all the
man-powered Brookins jr. aldermen
Michael Rodriguez alderman Levana
Tabares Feldman Michael Scott Jr
all men fire and seizure Lopez alderman
Roberto Maldonado alderman Walter
Burnett jr. alderman Jason urban
alderman free Calavera alderman Ariel
for boya aldeman felix cardona all
demands scott Waguespack all demand
Rosana Rodrigo Sanchez Haldeman Kerry
Austin almond Carlos Ramirez Rosa
Haldeman Gilbert Villegas all demand
Emma mix all demand Nicolas pasado
alderman Samantha huge n aldermen Andre
Vaska aldermen Anthony Napolitano Oldman
Brendan Reilly Aldrin Michelle Smith
almond Tom honey almond gym partner
alderman James Koppelman almond Matt
Martin almond Harry posterman alderman
Maria hadn't alderman Deborah
silverstein Your Honor we have a quorum
present we have a quorum
I now present to you for your
consideration the official bonds of the
Honorable Lori Lightfoot as mayor of the
city of Chicago their Honorable Ana
Valencia as the city clerk of Chicago
and the Honorable Melissa Conyers urban
as a treasurer of the city of Chicago
which have been certified as to form by
the corporation council and certified as
the sutures by the city comptroller
alderman O'Shea for a motion on the
bonds mr. president I move that the City
Council to approve the bonds for the
mayor clerk and treasurer Oh an alderman
O'Shea's motion to approve the bonds all
those in favor say aye those opposed say
no the eyes have it and the bonds are
approved mayor Manuel mayor elect
Lightfoot treasurer Conyers urban
members of the City Council the clerk of
Kirk County has filed in the office of
the city clerk official statements of
election for the offices of mayor city
clerk city treasurer and aldermen of the
50 Lords of the city of Chicago
and now the prayer for peace to be
delivered by Reverend dr. Beth Brown
good morning Chicago I am so excited to
be here with you today as we make her
story
as I lead us in prayer I want to invite
you to participate in a part of the
prayer which is call and response I'll
let you know when it's time it means you
have to pay attention let us join
together in prayer god of many names
tribes cultures and planets we are here
today in this place to pray for peace
for our city but what is peace there are
some among us who would settle for the
absence of war or violence or conflict
but you do not want us to settle there
in the Hebrew Scriptures we have a
vision of peace as Shalom or wholeness
or well-being in the great Greek
scriptures we have a vision of peace as
joining or binding together that which
has been separated or those who have
been separated or divided these two
visions together lead us to a peace that
includes wholeness and well-being and
joining together and the ability to
thrive for all people today and every
day going forward we pray to you for
this peace for our city and for every
person and every living thing in it all
of our major religions teach that we
should do to others what we want them to
do to us and we should refrain from
doing to others what we don't want them
to do to us these words are pathways to
peace we are here today to celebrate a
new day in Chicago we are grateful for
our newly elected officials and for
their willingness to serve in leadership
at this time as we make herstory
today by inaugurating Lori Lightfoot as
mayor help us to seize this moment to be
and to create the kind of change we want
to see going forward at this critical
juncture in our city we claim what we
know to be true we are enough and we
have enough in every neighborhood and
ward we have people with the gifts that
we need to bring us together across this
city from the south to the north from
the west to the east we have an
abundance of wealth knowledge talent
creativity persistence understanding
generosity and compassion what keeps us
from building and walking the road to
peace is that we get stuck in scarcity
thinking time and time again we act as
if there is great scarcity there is not
enough for everyone this prayer for
peace is a call for us to live the truth
of our abundance deepen in all of us the
desire to create a Chicago where there
is room enough for everyone
food enough for everyone
voice enough for everyone resources
enough for everyone opportunities enough
for everyone we heard throughout the
campaign from our new mayor that as a
city we are better together being better
together means no one gets left behind
[Music]
[Applause]
in this prayer let's practice being
better together as I pray about the work
we have to do I will end each thought by
asking how and you respond by saying we
are enough and we have enough let's hear
it we are enough and we have enough God
just as we did on April 2nd help us to
wage peace by literally joining hands
with people we don't even know across
our great city how we are enough and we
have enough help us to wage peace by
recognizing that every child in this
city is our child how we are enough and
we have enough help us to wage peace by
including and not excluding and by
refusing to leave a single person behind
how we are enough and we have enough
help us to wage peace by not playing
small and by realizing that each one of
us has gifts to bring and to offer our
city how we are enough and we have
enough help us to wage peace by our
commitment to creating one city where we
truly are better together how we are
enough and we have enough this prayer
for peace is audacious Oh God and will
require every one of us to become in the
words of the prophet Isaiah repairers of
the breach and restorers of the streets
to
we must repair our city because of the
historical and the current gaps there is
no peace that is an easy piece and we
will not settle for a false peace
because we are enough and we have enough
we pray for nothing less than
transformation as we repair our city and
restore our streets transform us and
transform our city we pray so that
together we will let our light shine
amen
the Honorable piece Scott Neville jr.
Supreme Court justice first district of
the Illinois Supreme Court will now
administer the oath of office to melissa
Conyers Ervin as treasurer of the city
of Chicago
please place your hand on the Bible and
raise your right hand and repeat after
me I Melissa
Conyers Irvin Melissa Kahn years Irvin
do solemnly swear do solemnly swear that
I will support the Constitution of the
United States that I will support the
Constitution of the United States and
the Constitution of the state of
Illinois and the constitution of the
state of Illinois and that I will
faithfully discharge and that I will
faithfully discharge the duties of the
office of treasurer the duties of the
office of treasurer of the city of
Chicago of the city of Chicago according
to the best of my ability according to
the best of my ability congratulations
you've been installed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please bow your
heads for the blessing to be delivered
by Rabbi capers SI phan a junior
let us pray
avinu Hashem I'm our Father in heaven we
come into your presence today on this
most auspicious occasion to ask for your
guidance and blessing upon this
administration and our mayor Lori
Lightfoot as we move from the season of
Passover to this 30th day of the
counting of the owner and the receiving
of the Torah we are mindful that we have
left behind
recently the Easter season and we enter
into the holy season of Ramadan may your
blessings flow from heaven upon all
faiths in our city of Chicago community
our community we are one community as
long as we stand united we can overcome
all obstacles so I say to our
communities from the west side the south
side the Near North Side to the far
north side to let us stand united behind
our mayor for the sages of the Talmud
have said if I am NOT for myself who
will be for me and if I am only for
myself what am i and if not now when
this threefold dictum refers to man's
spiritual goals this teaches us that if
I do not rouse my soul to higher things
who arouse it if I do not fulfill the
commandments
who will fulfill them for me if I am NOT
for myself even I make success efforts
to grow spiritually there is still so
much more for me to do consequently I
can never be satisfied with myself some
comment that although man must work hard
to perfect himself he must not forget
that he is a part of a group a community
that both helps him for her and should
share in her accomplishments so our
prayer today is that we stand united as
one community one city as we go forward
from strength to strength and may you
bless our mayor Lori Lightfoot with
wisdom with understanding with patients
and with unity in every community our
God and the God of our forefathers bless
us with the three verse blessings in the
Torah that was written by the hand of
Moshe your servant that was said by AHA
Ron and his sons the coniine your holy
people and it is said may the Lord bless
you and keep you may the Lord illuminate
his countenance for you and be gracious
to you
may the Lord turned his countenance to
you and established peace for you and
let us say
amang
the Honorable Susan ich ox magistrate
judge for the US District Court for the
Northern District of Illinois will now
administer the oath of office to Lori
Lightfoot as mayor of the city of
Chicago I Laurie Elaine Lightfoot I
Laurie Elaine Lightfoot to soundly swear
do solemnly swear that I will support
the Constitution of the United States
and I will support the Constitution of
the United States and the Constitution
of the state of Illinois and the
Constitution of the state of Illinois
and that I will faithfully discharge the
duties and I will faithfully discharge
the duties of the office of mayor of the
office of mayor of the city of Chicago
of the city of Chicago according to the
best of my ability according to the best
of my ability so help me God so help me
God congratulations
[Applause]
[Applause]
please thank you thank you so very much
as I stand as your mayor humble and
hopeful honored to be the 56th mayor of
this great city we are a proud city with
a proud history in this moment I can't
help but look at all of you and think
about what lies ahead and what we can be
together I'm looking ahead to a city of
safe streets and strong schools for
every child regardless of neighborhood
or zip code a city where people want to
grow old and not flee a city of
sanctuary against fear where no one must
hide in the shadows a city that is
affordable for families and seniors and
where every job pays a living wage a
city of fairness and hope and prosperity
for many not just for the few a city
that holds equity and inclusion as our
guiding principles Chicago is not where
my story began but from the moment that
I arrived in Hyde Park to attend law
school and begin my career this is a
city where I belonged it's where I met
the love of my life my wife Amy it's
where our daughter Vivian was born and
she's growing up to be into the kind
curious and spirited young woman that I
always knew she would be
for me this city has given me such
opportunity it's been a city of hope as
I stand here today I can't help but
think about where I came from and I know
in my heart that a story like mine of a
kid growing up in a working-class family
growing up to realize the dreams of my
father and my mother through education
hard work and sheer determination needs
to be the story of possibility in every
neighborhood
children who look like me and come from
families like mine shouldn't have to
beat the odds to get education pursue
their passions or build a family black
and brown kids low-income kids every kid
in this city should know should grow up
knowing they can pursue anything they
can love anyone
that's my Chicago dream
and I know we're just a little bit
closer to that dream as I stand here
today inaugurated as Chicago's first
black woman mayor and first openly gay
and I know we're a little bit closer as
we celebrate that for the first time in
the history of Chicago women of color
now hold all three citywide
I congratulate you City Clerk Anna
Valencia and city treasurer militia
Conyers urban on your inaugurations your
victories and all you've done to
overcome to reach this historic moment I
also congratulate the alderman of the
Chicago City Council in particular the
12 aldermen who are taking their seats
for the first time let's give them
around
I think mayor Emanuel for his dedication
as service to this city which was
exemplified by the tension and time that
he and his staff devoted to making this
transition as smooth as possible
and I also commend any rule for her
contributions to the city join me in
wishing them both well as they head off
into the next chapter of their lives
and I also want to acknowledge and thank
the other leaders here today governor JB
Pritzker lieutenant governor Julianne
Stratton Senator Dick Durbin senator
tammy duckworth and our congressional
Illinois congressional delegation Cook
County board president Tony pret Winkle
representatives from our state
legislature and every other elected
official here today thank you for your
continued service most importantly
though I want to thank the people of
Chicago who had the courage to put their
faith in a newcomer and the optimism to
join this moment we stand today at a
time of great hope and possibility I
can't help but feel the spirit of the
great late mayor Harold Washington here
now there's one person that you are
about to meet who laid the foundation
for everything that I am today
I want to introduce you to a former
elected official with us a one-time
school board member from my hometown of
Maslin she's my role model my champion
one man on whose dreams and high
expectations propelled me through life
my mother
my mom is nine years old and forgive me
for disclosing that and doesn't travel
much these days
but nothing could keep her or my
siblings Derek
Angela Brian and Stacy from being here
today
my mother and my late father Elijah gave
us the best they could in this town that
we grew up in even when they had almost
nothing else to give as parents they led
by example they instilled in me a clear
set of values loyalty to family friends
and community and the importance of hard
work education and integrity and mom
most importantly you and dad told me
that I could be anything that I wanted
to be I could not be held back by my
race gender or family financial status
that I should hold my head up high and
not like anyone else dictate my destiny
or my future that knoweth all was out of
reach that no victory was too unlikely
to pursue I feel my father's present
here today my gratitude to you both has
no limit just like when I was a little
girl I'm working hard to make you proud
to honor your sacrifice to live by the
values you instilled in me to make sure
that families like ours don't have to
struggle like we did I look out today
and I see a proud city with a proud
history here in Chicago right here our
people invented the skyscraper in the
ferris wheel here our people invented
our own Chicago Blues our people
generations of industrious hard-working
people who built one of the greatest
cities ever to grace God's earth
and I stand here today as your mayor
humble and hopeful and I make one solemn
promise to the generations who came
before us and to the generations yet to
come
we will continue to build this great
city and leave it better stronger fair
or more prosperous than when we found it
the challenges we faced today did not
arise overnight and they will not be
solved overnight but they and they
certainly won't be saved and solved by
one mare acting alone in this important
moment let us remember the powerful
words of Chicago's Port Louis laureate
Gwendolyn Brooks she said we are each
other's harvest we are each other's
business and we are each other's
magnitude and bond folks we must be in
this together our challenges can only be
solved if we face them together we
cannot fail we will not fail we are
Chicago
I also remember so many people I met in
the city who can't be here today who
will never see the inside of a room like
this the big guy who came to hear me
speak and then followed me outside on a
cold blustery day on the southeast side
and pleaded lorry just bring us jobs
just bring us jobs we want to work the
teenagers that I met on the south side
kicked out of their homes and left on
the streets at night in the bitter cold
with no food or shelter just because
they were gay or trans the father on the
west side who told me he was scared
scared to death every time his three
daughters left the house those girls are
his whole world and he's worried
somebody's going to gun them down the
countless number of people who daily
fear whose daily fear is that ice would
come for them as they took their kids to
school stood as day laborers or just
walked in their neighborhoods we should
never forget that these are the people
who put us here we are each other's
business and standing up for them is our
business our only business
now there are four stars on Chicago's
flag each standing for a point in our
history the construction of Fort
Dearborn the great expositions of 1893
in 1933 and the reconstruction of our
city following the great fire each star
stands for building and rebuilding today
we should proudly reinterpret these four
stars with new meaning for a new citrus
century with new challenges and
opportunities that lie ahead guiding our
city and guiding our new administration
as we move forward and rebuild again
today we reimagine the first star
standing for safety in every
neighborhood people cannot and should
not live in neighborhoods that resemble
a war zone and not for the shooting
enough of the guns enough of the
violence bless unite in our response to
the biggest challenge we face the
epidemic of gun violence that devastates
families shatters communities buries
dreams and holds children hostage in
their homes for fear it inflicts
lifelong trauma that spreads through our
communities like a virus when we hear a
random bullet cutting a life short
people across the city from all ages and
walks of life begin to wonder if Chicago
is a place where they can continue to
live and raise their children some have
already answered the question by moving
away particularly from the hardest hit
communities the mass exodus that we have
seen particularly in the black community
saps the vitality of our great city we
must reverse the Exodus by creating the
reality of safety in every neighborhood
public safety must not be a commodity
that
only available to the wealthy
and what this means for me is that there
is no higher calling than restoring
safety and peace in our neighborhoods we
will develop a new proactive strategy in
partnership with the communities hardest
hit by the scourge of gun violence all
of our stakeholders must be committed to
this work now this is not a challenge
that can be solved by law enforcement
alone nor will we place the blame on
communities on people and communities
who are under siege know this greatest
challenge demands all of us United
together and I promise you the city will
lead and we've already begun this work